Hey, Michael.
Hi, Ara, how are you?
I'm doing good. How are you? How's your week so far?
He has been busy.
Really, BC? What's going on?
Yeah, it has just a lot of work, a lot of meetings, you know, yeah.
Yeah, same here. Is that related to your quarter review?
Yes, and then pass a lot of that other things going on too.
Okay, gotcha. How about personally? How are you?
Oh, that's a loaded question. That's a loaded question because I am, I love soccer, right? Football, right? And every,
Great question.
Yeah.
One month every four years, my life stops and revolves around the World Cup.
The World Cup starts today and it's one month where I have no other life but the World Cup. So I am very excited about it.
Wow, you're a fan, football fan.
Yes, yes, um, so then I had...
Favorite Team.
Well, I mean, my country did not qualify. So in reality, at the end of the day, I don't care. I just want to see good games and I, you know, I get to enjoy them. And, you know, I do this every four years for one month and people know not to bother me during that time.
Yeah.
What?
Haha.
Yeah, anyways, good for you. You have waited for so long and now it's happening. So hopefully your favorite team, even though you don't have one, I hope they'll win. And then anyways, for me, don't have anything new.
I just traveled like way back May, and then you know about that, and that's it.
OK.
Yup.
Samson.
Here we go. Hi, Natalie. Thanks for joining.
Hey, Ayra. Hey, Marco.
Hey, hey Natalie, how you doing?
Doing well, doing well. I was at Pax 8 this week, so it was a cool event. They had 50 cent, Marco.
Oh wow, that's crazy.
Yeah, yeah, it was so tight, and then, like, we were like pretty much in front row as well, so it was cool.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Does he still sound good?
Yeah, he was, he had like all of his chains on too, like he had all the diamonds and he had those like 2 hype guys with him. I'll send you a video. It's, yeah, it was pretty cool. Because they always get like a good like rap artist. Like they had Snoop Dogg last year and like Nelly the year before. And now Pax 8 too, like they're bigger than IT Nation. So Pax 8's like officially the biggest.
Oh, that's awesome.
Uh, event in the channel now that 3500, 3500 people were there.
Wow.
I'm shocked.
Yeah, it was like, even when I walked in, I was like, oh, it's hot in here. There's so many people like, and it was a large, it was like a convention center in Salt Lake City. So it was like a big venue too.
Wow.
That was cool.
That's awesome.
What's your favorite moment there, Nat?
I honestly, I really enjoyed, so like I was, Ankur was with me as well, so even Ankur, like he's, this is a little bit newer to him, like he's been to build it, but like now he's going to IT Nation, he's coming to Pax 8 and like going to these other events. So that's fun for me and like we'll sit at lunch and then
We just talk, so like the lunchtime, like you're just talking to different MSPs or vendors that are at the table with you. And like we were talking to this one MSP who's just kind of newer and like we really are able to like give that advice on like what they should do to like start growing their MSP and like then now they may join our community.
Right, we're going to try to get them to come to build it, join the peer groups and everything.
Cool.
Yeah.
Cool. Lucky, luckily, Marco will be joining this year, yeah?
Oh yeah, Marco is one of our favorite Build It members, so he's going to be on. If we had a board, you'd be on the Build It board.
Yeah.
Oh, hell yeah.
Yes.
Hell yeah, I like that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Anyways, thank you so much guys for wanting our power meeting today. So let me just quickly share my screen and let me know once this is visible. Just give me a second.
PH.
Natalie, are you going to any of the games in Dallas?
I'm not. I did enter a raffle through the tool, the tool booth. I noticed I had a lot of points in there and like one of them was to enter a raffle. So we'll see if I get some free tickets, but I haven't bought or like looked at any anything yet, but who knows?
Yeah.
My son is here, so.
There's they're very expensive, but you know.
Yeah, exactly. I assumed that they were very expensive, so like I had to need to start in the DAB.
I'm trying to see if I can score some a good deal at last second. So we'll see.
Yeah, right. Exactly.
I'm going to be in New York City this Saturday and try to see if I can score. I take it for Brazil and Morocco.
Ohh, one.
Yeah, do you watch basketball? Did you see the game last night?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, this is insane, insane.
It was insane. It was absolutely insane. I agree.
Anyway, sorry, Ayra.
Yeah, I was like, I really, how did you, what did you do? How did you get this tab? Look at it, it's moving and grooving. Wow.
It's fine, it's fine.
I took it out from their website.
Well, look at that. That's cool.
The.
Yeah, they have a very cool website.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I love that.
Yeah, no. Yeah, it's cute. It's cool. So this is going to be our week 13th and then the review duration will be from the past two weeks. That's from May 25 to June 5.
Moving on to the agenda items, that's pretty much the same. Check in, this is for you, Marco. Anything new, any challenges, anything you want to share?
No, I mean, things are going well. Jane continues to grab a healthy amount of tickets. She's managing and triaging tickets, you know, for the most part, well. I mean, there's still that learning curve, but I think she's
doing well. She's, she seems to work well with all her peers. So, I mean, not real issues at all.
Great to hear. Yeah, it's just been like more than three months, right? What do you think could she improve?
I mean, I don't know if necessarily improved yet. I think that's just going to come with time as she gets more and more used to things. So I, you know, I wouldn't necessarily say that there's like a big thing going on. I mean, I did.
stress this, not just her, but like the entire team is just about taking the time to making sure that whatever ticket they are triaging, they have gotten all the information that they need before they move it over to whatever team it will be. So that meant.
you know, maybe potentially keeping the client a little longer on on the call as they're prepping the ticket and documenting it. But that was not just specific to her, that was specific to the entire group.
The.
Yeah.
Gotcha. So what I'm hearing is that it's very important that we document everything, be specific, right? Elaborate the issue so that when a tech or an L1 receives the ticket, that person will receive the overview, right?
Right. Correct. Correct.
of the issue. Yeah, I understand. Okay, sure. So that's perfect. Thanks for the feedback. And I'll work on her with that because I'm doing the weekly board reviews, which you allowed. So thank you for that. Action tracker, I have here too. One for you, Marco. We have sent out the CSAT feedback for Jane.
Mhm.
That's going to be for the month of May. So please, if you have time, please search near mailbox. That should be from Partner Feedback.
Okay.
And then for the other item, that's for me. So I'm still doing the board reviews. So that's just 30 minutes every Monday.
Mhm.
Okay, performance analysis, yep, here we go. For KPIs, you're aware of this, all the same.
Right.
Utilization trend. So what we have here is just for seven working days because she was out sick. She was out sick for two days and then she was also out Memorial Day, May 25th.
Mhm.
Remember our target to get the 250, she needs to get 12 calls per day. So we're on a good start.
For triage and dispatch, I can see there's an increase on this one from the last week. We closed at 145 tickets. So that's all the service tickets she worked on. Any questions on this slide?
Mhm.
No.
Okay, I tried doing something else. I did try to audit 5 tickets.
And then according to the KPIs that we're targeting, we have the triage accuracy, time to assign, 5 to 15 minutes, SLA response, category accuracy, like is she putting in the right type and subtype.
right, categorization of the ticket, plus the queue hygiene that includes internal notes, summary, any grammar or a typo. So that five tickets, it's wonderful. That's 100% compliant.
So she always makes sure that she assigns the ticket within 15 minutes. She has a currency. I can see she's assigning it to the correct board. So what I'm guessing here is that what I can see here is she got a very good mentor. So in case you see any ticket that
Yeah.
has been incorrectly assigned or there are some categorization inaccuracy, please do flag it to me so I can discuss and pull it out, the ticket report so we can discuss it together during our weekly review. Okay?
Okay.
But for the past two weeks, she's very good.
And here are the IT by Design products that's all the same. If you're interested, Shield IT Pro Services, or if you need any engineers, just let us know.
Build it, you're coming, so that's that, and lastly, for the way forward, Marco, if it's OK with you.
to transition the bi-weekly to monthly service call because I want to make sure that I'm composing and I'm getting all the data accurately. So I want to give you the monthly report. And that would help me navigate or understand if we're missing something out with regards to Jane's performance.
So if you want to keep it bi-weekly, that's fine. What do you think?
I mean, we can move monthly. That's not really a problem.
Yeah, but then if you have urgent concerns, we have the Team channel, right? You can reach out to us as always. Okay, so we'll start next month then. So I'll present all the data, all the charts that we need to gauge change performance.
S.
Right, right, correct, right.
And that's it. That's the end of my slide here. Anything you want to add here, Nat? Any news?
No, I don't have any anything. Thank you though.
No worries. How are you, Michael?
So...
A question for you, because do you really want every ticket that?
You know, let's call it there was a little mistake or a little thing in there. I mean...
I don't usually do that because it gets to be a little nitpicking. I mean, if she processed, let's say, 100 tickets, right, and I have 3 tickets that she didn't process right.
The.
Is that really a problem or is it just a human behavior that we know that a mistake is going to happen?
Thank you.
So, I mean, if you, if you...
Well, we do still want to assess the risk and try to mitigate and, yeah, not having stuff.
Yes.
Well, but I mean, but I, right, but I mean, that's my point. So, like, I have I have two things, right? That I know the the could have been the could have been handled better, but at the end of the day.
You know, there was not really a huge issue, no, and and and and and the client and the client didn't really get affected in a negative way. I mean, one, you know, there were...
Nobody died, is what you're saying? Nobody died.
Yeah, which is much is the most important thing, right? Client impact, like it was the client impact.
Right, like, for instance, there was one ticket that you know a client had called requesting a quote for a computer, and she sent that ticket to Helpdesk instead of the sales team. OK, it's a mistake in terms of how it was triaged, but out of all the other tickets that she triaged properly.
Yeah.
is that really so much of a big issue? And that's why I'm like, you know, if you want to know, I can give you that, but it just seems like it will be kind of like a little nitpicking because in that one, I didn't even bother to say anything to her because it's not that she doesn't know that, it's just that, okay, she made a mistake out of like the so many tickets that she has
Process properly in there, so there has, it was not an error that I will go and say, well, you know, um...
Yeah, it was an oversight. Like it wasn't like she doesn't know what to do or needs additional training. It was just she's moving quickly and she accidentally put on the wrong board.
Right.
So I mean, if you want that, if you want that, I can give that to you, but it just...
Okay, well...
So no, that's where you can assess that, right? So assess it in that way. Is this something that she needs to learn? And now you need that help from Ayra to just firm and make sure that she does truly understand this process? Or is it just a one-off, right? We don't need to know the one-offs. Obviously, the client's impacted and
Again, if you want us to support on our side with your message, just let us know, right?
Right.
Okay, I just want to make sure that we were on the same page in there because I was like, I mean, I, you know, it just feels kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're not, we're not trying to kill morale or anything like that, right? We get it, we get it. No.
No.
Yeah, of course. I don't want to be nitpicky. Yeah, we're just doing this. So we want to make sure that we provide you with the quality service that we promise. So as much as possible, when I flag something, I reach out to her and I do coach her. But in terms of the percentage,
Yeah.
PH.
If it's one out of 10, that wouldn't be a problem. That's going to be still 90, 99%. So we're talking about numbers. So if that's one mistake out of 10, it's fine. But then if the impact, just like what Natalie is saying, if a client or it's affected.
the SLA or the client or anything, you can let us know so we can flag it early on.
Right, you know, and, and, and that, and that's fine. I mean, yeah, and I'm trust me.
I am not shy to vocalize when I see problems. So, you know, by the time it gets to you, like if there was a problem like that, I already talked to her about it. You know what I mean? So just, you know, I'm not the one that is going to sweep something under the rug because I may hurt someone's feeling. I don't really care about that.
Ultimately, you know, you know, I know it sounds harsh, but I'm running a business and not running a charity here.
Yeah.
I like how you come in like super hard after you were kind of soft like 5 minutes ago and now you're like, just so you know, I am running this business.
Ha ha ha.
Well, I mean, I, I, I need to be hard on what I need to be hard on. I can't, you know, you know...
Okay.
I know, I can't, no, it's a, yeah, you gotta pick your battles, right? Pick your battles.
Right. I mean, you did something that caused a client relationship. I am going to be hard on that. You move a computer request to the inside of the sales team to like the Helpdesk.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's a.
I don't get all that, you know, it's not a big deal.
Yeah, but yeah, we appreciate you, Marco, for being empathetic. That's what we want for every manager, especially your manager, your director, you know, that's not very common. So I do understand that when you're on that position, you need to be direct and you need to be assertive, right, Natalie? So we appreciate you being like that.
So.
Yeah, you know. Thank you. Thank you.
Wow, there's a there is a side of Natalie, I guess I don't know, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, because before we were doing like Natalie was coaching me before that I need to be assertive, especially you're in a lead role, right? People need to believe you, to trust you because you're a leader. Yeah, but then I overcome, yeah.
And.
But.
Yeah, yeah, no, Ayra, you're doing great, so...
Thank you so much, Dad. Anyway, so much for me. Anything else, Team, you want to discuss here? Shall we drop off?
I, I'm good.
Good? Okay. Yeah, this is so productive and it's so cool. Cool meeting.
The.
Alright, thank you guys. Goodbye.
Alright, awesome. Thank you, guys. Alright, you too. Alright, bye.
Happy weekend, everyone! You enjoy. Bye-bye.